[Musique]
e
l'avènement du numérique mantoue nous
parle de son petit contribuer à une
meilleure démocratie
beaucoup pensent qu'une plus grande
implication du public dans la sphère
politique est souhaitable c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
je pense que des solutions sont
possibles en utilisant les outils
numériques
c'est un nous demandent de réfléchir au
fonctionnement de ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence collective et à partir de
là de concevoir des systèmes des
langages et des outils pour une
démocratie plus participative dans mon
point de départ c'est l'observation
qu'en démocratie
l'opinion publique compte car les
dirigeants doivent obtenir notre
adhésion
ne serait ce que pour se faire élire et
lorsqu'ils sont élus pour faire accepter
leur décision
doug bien sûr la tentation de manipuler
l'opinion publique voire de maintenir la
population dans l'ignorance pour
l'assujettir aux décisions des experts
qui serve leurs intérêts ou du moins de
ne pas impliquer le public dans des
débats dont les conclusions pourraient
ne pas abonder dans leur sens les
politiques disent souvent avoir écouté
leurs concitoyens et répondre à leurs
demandes
mais le plus souvent nous rencontrer que
leurs militants ou leurs sympathisants
qui leur disent ce qu'ils ont envie
d'entendre
et le débat reste confinée entre des
personnes qui partagent les mêmes
opinions
il ya donc un véritable intérêt à se
réapproprier son opinion et à la
confronter à celles des autres une
véritable démocratie doit s'attacher à
construire une compréhension partagée du
monde dans lequel on vit des enjeux
auxquels on est confrontés est de
permettre l'émergence d'une opinion
publique éclairée et non manipulée à la
base la démocratie nous permet de
choisir de façon transparente non
représentants
et il est vrai que la vie collective est
quelque chose de sérieux extrêmement
complexe c'est un vrai métier il faut
être bien formés pour cela
nos dirigeants sortent des grandes
écoles d'administration ils ont les
compétences requises et on ne doit pas
douter a priori de leur dévouement
les embauches sont des contrats
déterminée pour nous administrer mais
doit-on pour cela lors d'années carte
blanche et n'évalue leur travail que
termes de leur contrat et mieux ce
contrat n'est ce pas nous qui devrions
le rédiger lorsque vous faites des
travaux chez vous c'est vous qui
définissent et vos besoins des artisans
réfléchissent à des solutions techniques
on évalue les coûts et vous choisissez
le mieux disant
l'artisan est le spécialiste certes mais
c'est vous le client et comme l'exprimé
john dit oui un sociologue et philosophe
américain du 20e siècle
c'est la personne qui porte la chaussure
qui sait mieux si elle fait mal et où
elle fait mal même si le cordonnier est
l'expert qui est le meilleur juge pour
savoir y remédier pour dire oui la
démocratie ne se limite pas à consulter
de temps en temps les citoyens au moyen
du suffrage universel
elle doit être participative ce qui
signifie d'une part que les citoyens
doivent être pleinement informés des
enjeux et qu'il puisse de manière
collaborative contribuer à la recherche
de solutions aux problèmes qui les
concernent donc là la première étape
d'une démarche participative c'est que
nous soyons pleinement informés lors de
ce point de vue internet a contribué à
changer la donne parce qu'il nous permet
d'accéder rapidement à une information
précise riche documenté je ne sais pas
ce qu'il en est pour vous mais pour moi
lors de repas entre amis c'est acquis
dégaine le plus rapidement son
smartphone pour vérifier ou compléter
une information et en quelques secondes
internet a mis tout le monde d'accord
alors cet instrument qui accessoirement
peut servir à téléphoner est devenue une
véritable prothèse cognitifs et il s'est
répandu aux quatre coins de la planète
ce qui fait que des jeunes qui vivent
dans des pays pauvres ou rétrograde voit
ce qui se passe ailleurs et ont envie de
changer les choses
chez eux donc ne serait ce que par
l'information qu'il véhicule et son
caractère universel internet a des
effets bénéfiques pour la démocratie
alors l'outil le plus remarquable dans
cet opus écosystème numérique est selon
moi un wikipédien car il montre de façon
probante que l'intelligence collective
mise en avant par john dit oui ça peut
marcher
imaginez-vous quelques années en arrière
il ya une conférence comme celle si
quelqu'un vous annonce qu'il souhaite
créer une encyclopédie en ligne où
chacun pourra contribuer librement
je pense que vous seriez dit et moi le
premier
oui et bien bon courage
et pourtant ça marche c'était un succès
improbable mais incontestable alors en
coin wikipedia peut-il nous inspirer
pour imaginer une forme de démocratie
numérique
et bien parce qu'il s'agit d'un c'est un
exemple de ce qu'on appelle en bon
français du crowdsourcing aux crocs dans
l'anglais ça signifie la foule
il s'agit donc d'application qui sont
alimentés par la foule
on va solliciter un grand nombre de gens
pour faire des tâches et l'ordinateur ne
s'est pas fait ne saurais pas faire de
manière satisfaisante
ces informations sont ensuite traitées
par des algorithmes
afin de transformer cette multitude de
petites contributions en quelque chose
d'utile
donc on peut faire la une une analogie
avec le filage du coton vous savez que
la fibre naturelle de la fleur de coton
est courte et fragile mais si vous
tordez ces fibres les unes sur les
autres vous allez produire un fil plus
résistant que vous pourrez ensuite
tissés pour produire des vêtements de la
même façon l'intelligence collective
n'émerge pas de façon spontanée ne
suffit pas de réunir des gens de leur
permettre de s'exprimer comme par
exemple sur les réseaux sociaux pour que
cela crée automatiquement de la
connaissance ou qu'on aboutisse à des
prises de décisions rationnelles
non si vous amassez beaucoup de coton
tout ce que vous allez obtenir c'est un
gros entre-temps et un quota de thon ce
n'est pas une chemise un déjà il ya pas
les boutons alors ma conviction c'est
que l'informatique peut produire ces
outils de filage et de tissage qui
permettent de construire du savoir à
partir de données brutes qui le plus
souvent sont imprécises incertaine et
parfois contradictoires alors si on fait
pas ce travail on va se contenter de
d'accumuler l'information sans la
traiter sans les hiérarchiser
sans la critiquer et on va aboutir à une
position relativiste dans laquelle tout
avis se vaut et donc rien n'a de valeur
ce qui fait le lit des idées les plus
stupides
les théories les plus farfelues voire de
propos intolérables et ça on le voit
aussi sur internet et sa porte
de l'eau au moulin de gens ils sont
sceptiques sur le rôle accordé au public
dans la sphère politique alors joseph
schumpeter été un de ceux là
c'était un un économiste un spécialiste
en sciences politiques un contemporain
de john dit oui mais qui visiblement ne
partagez pas sa vision
voici ce qu'il disait le citoyen typique
tombe à un niveau inférieur de
performance mentale dès qu'ils entrent
dans le champ de la politique il
argumenté analyse d'une façon qu'il
reconnaîtra immédiatement comme
infantile dans la sphère de ses intérêts
réels il devient primitif sa pensée
devient associatif et affectif bon en
résumé et dans le langage tous les jours
nous sommes tous des idiots et nos
arguments sont débiles c'est vrai au
moins si on prend ces termes dans leur
sens littéral mais doit-on en déduire
pour autant que notre avis ne compte pas
le point de vue de son péters ne tient
plus si on considère qu'on dispose
d'outils ils vont pouvoir faire de la
connaissance à partir de contributions
imparfaite
ces outils devrait réguler la
conversation sur internet en orchestrant
les actes de langage qui apparaît lors
d'une discussion critique
alors laissez-moi vous donner un exemple
de la façon dont ça se passe lors d'une
conversation ordinaire alors comme
l'informatique s'appliqua à beaucoup de
domaines je suis parfois conduit à
m'intéresser à des sujets que je ne
maîtrise pas et mes interlocuteurs ne
sont pas des spécialistes en
informatique
ce qui veut dire qu'on est tous
inexpérimenté au moins sur certains
aspects du problème
on a chacun notre part des diots si on
n'est pas fier mais c'est comme ça alors
dans une telle discussion je peux est
amené à faire une proposition et a
commencé à développer un argumentaire va
bien sûr cet argumentaire va être
fragile un peu débile si vous voulez
parce qu'il ya des choses qui sont
imprécises il ya des hypothèses qui sont
implicites et des arguments qui
devraient être mieux développer redire
je cherche autant à me convaincre moi
même qu'à convaincre mes interlocuteurs
et c'est là une discussion critique se
met en place
on me demande de préciser certaines
définitions pour être sûr qu'on se
comprenne bien et qu'on parle de la même
chose
les interlocuteurs pourront émettre des
doutes faire des objections
ils pourront tenter de réfuter certain
point je me sens obligé de défendre ma
position en développant davantage nos
arguments je serai peut-être obligés de
faire des concessions nous des
amendements mais je peux aussi être
soutenus par d'autres participants qui
vont abonder dans le sens avec toutes
ces interactions à mon argumentation se
renforcent et gagnent en crédibilité
mais il se peut néanmoins que je me
rende compte que je n'arriverai pas à
répondre à certaines objections
la proposition ne tient pas la route je
file un mauvais coton
à ce moment là j'en fais le deuil
oublions ça c'était stupide et notre
attention se porte sur d'autres pistes
est ce qu'on peut considérer plusieurs
pistes à la fois qui ne sont pas
nécessairement contradictoires
par contre si on arrive à des
antagonismes irréductibles c'est à dire
qu'ils ne peuvent pas conduire à un
consensus
il nous faudra trouver le point de
divergence
il fera remonter jusqu'à l'origine du
conflit
quelle est la question clivante cette
question que se trouve sur la ligne de
crête et dont la réponse et termine de
quel côté
on souhaite s'orienter donc globalement
un conte un débat bien conduit est telle
qu'on aimerait le mettre en place sur
internet devrait permettre à la fois de
construire une compréhension partagée du
problème en des termes compréhensibles
par tous de consolider les positions par
des argumentations précises et
documentées et d'éliminer des
propositions qui ne résiste pas à la
critique et ça devrait aussi permettre
de faire ressortir les vraies questions
c'est irsn et correspondent aux clivages
qui sont apparues pendant la discussion
parce qu'un sondage peut effectivement
donner une image de l'opinion publique
qui fait sens à condition que ces
questions soient mises dans leur
contexte ou mieux comme ici qu'elles
soient issues de la discussion elle même
alors en informatique théorie on
s'intéresse beaucoup à ce qu'on appelle
les méthodes formelles
alors ça signifie pas qu'on s'intéresse
aux formalismes pour lui-même voire
parfois peut-être mais le mot forme elle
fait référence à la forme art position
au fond quand on cherche à modéliser la
forme d'un débat bien conduit on va
faire abstraction du contenu des
propositions pour s'intéresser à leurs
interactions
on cherche à savoir comment le système
évolue quelle est sa dynamique
on ne cherche pas
ah vous ne s'intéressent pas disons au
contenu de la discussion à sa
signification qui n réf sous le contrôle
des personnes qui participent aux débats
on veut juste s'assurer une discussion
critique se met effectivement en place
et non pas un ensemble de monologues
alors ces outils doivent aussi permettre
de façon régulière de construire une
synthèse du débat et éventuellement
d'extraire un sondage associé au clivage
qui sont apparues lors de la discussion
alors davantage de deux de faire le
débat à l'aide de ces outils numériques
et de l'ouvrir à tous par ailleurs ces
outils peuvent être efficaces pour la
conduite d'un débat pour au moins trois
raisons la forme écrite fait que les
arguments sont explicités et donc exposé
à la critique
le caractère asynchrone à l'auditeur
peuvent facilement abusé son auditoire
excusez moi un orateur peut facilement à
bizet son auditoire mais c'est un
argument vous met mal à l'aise vous
aurez ici le temps d'y réfléchir de vous
documenter d'en discuter de formuler vos
remarques ou vos critiques et enfin le
caractère massif
il aura au moins quelqu'un dans la foule
des participants qui ne se fera pas
abuser par un argument fallacieux et
apportera la contradiction
par ailleurs les informations qui seront
ainsi produits seront pérennes
facilement accessibles au public et
pourront s'enrichir au cours du temps
bien sûr encore faut-il que les gens
aient envie
d'investir un tel outil vous me direz
que vous préférez acheter vos chemises
plutôt que de les faire vous même moi
aussi mais peut-être sera ton tenter de
participer à un débat parce qu'on est
particulièrement sensible aux sujets
qu'ils abordent pour les autres sujets
on aura juste l'envi la curiosité de
comprendre et peut-être le désir de
donner son avis en répondant au sondage
chercher à comprendre c'est commencer à
désobéir disent les militaires les
chercher à comprendre et ne pas hésiter
à critiquer ou à faire des propositions
c'est une attitude civique et finalement
on pourrait être fiers de porter la
chemise qu'on a nous mêmes consul non
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
mais
[Musique]